is venom going to appear in the mcu more
specifically in the new movie spider-man
no way home for some who haven't seen
venom 2 let there be carnage there is a
spoiler for you in this video so wait
it's been more than a month now so deal
with it anyway venom let there be
cottage has a post-credits scene with
the symbiote and eddie brock chilling
and reminiscing about life and all that
jazz and when venom was about to share
the collective knowledge of the
symbiotes with eddie there was a rift in
the timeline and they were transported
into the mcu
and this is evident with the news
showing tom holland spider-man after
which venom licked the screen and
creepily said this guy
well the question now is will venom
appear in spider-man no way home or will
he be teased again in yet another credit
scene after the movie
it would be so much fun if venom entered
the fray with the other villains of the
next movie that i confirm and there is a
serious chance that this will happen as
this movie is a crossover between the
mcu and sony spiderman's universe and it
also might include venom as well as he
is owned by sony but that's not the
point i want to make the speculation
that i have is much deeper than just
this but let me ease a little bit into
my point by explaining something first
we are going to learn a little bit about
the sinister six they are a group of
super villains appearing in spider-man
comic books published by marvel comics
they are drawn from spider-man's list of
enemies the original incarnation of the
group was organized by dr octopus and
consisted of himself vulture electro
mysterio sandman and craven the hunter
and since mcu has already showcased the
vulture and mysterio and we barely see
villains from standalone mcu movies to
reappear again in a big part we
therefore end up with a few missing
members of the sinister six and it is
known that there have been quite a few
changes in the roster of the six over
the years
as of now we have five villains that are
seen and confirmed in spider-man no way
home these are dr octopus the villain
with four robotic tentacles that are
integrated to the genius bad guy we also
see the green goblin who is one of the
main arch rivals of spider-man then we
have sandman the character with the
ability to shape-shift and turn to san
we see electro making a scene in the
trailer as well and the lizard both of
which are main villains in the amazing
spider-man movies so that makes 5 out of
6 members of the sinister six
if that group so happens to form in the
new upcoming flick but yeah we also have
one more vacant seat hm who is it gonna
be
i wonder
so what if and yes let me say it again
this is just mere speculation but it's
backed up by some post-credit scenes
information from venom too so what if
venom joined and became the sixth member
of the group
let me put out a couple of points to
support this theory so venom was about
to share a tiny bit of the symbiote
collective knowledge with eddie
he also stated that it is a collective
memory of all the symbiotes in 80
billion light years of the multiverse
the multiverse which means that there is
a memory of him fighting spider-man in
the tobey maguire universe and of him
being beaten by the spider-man of that
universe so he might join the group to
get revenge on the mcu spider-man just
for that
as we can see him licking the screen and
seeing this guy as if he has met him
before
so second point venom has also
temporarily joined the sinister six in
the past issues just to target
spider-man replacing doctor octopus but
after the other members of the league
betrayed him he subsequently targets the
other members out of revenge
this might turn out as a plot twist in
the upcoming movie the present venom is
an anti-hero and is heavily influenced
by eddie brock's attitude and morals he
also has become kind of a good guy so
even his rage and instincts drive him to
attack spidey along the way with the
other five
there might come a time when he would
change sides as a result of eddie
brock's conscience and actually join
spidey as an ally who i wish that will
happen
so yeah
that's all i have to theorize for now
and since the movie is coming out in a
couple of weeks i'm just itchy to
analyze the movie when it comes out and
can't hardly wait
anyway with that we come to the end of
the video do hit that like button for
support and click on that subscribe
button as well to be a part of the mind
cue family
and most of all smash that bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam